在孩子今天情绪之所以出问题，
可能很大一部分原因是基于你情绪反复在拉扯，
情绪反复在内耗，
情绪反复陷在负面的人际关系当中拔不出来，
所以孩子才会变成那样。
如果你想救救你的孩子，
很多时候就是要把你从这些负面的人际关系当中抽离出来，
当断则断，
我今年40岁，
我的老公也是一样，
09年结婚了，
一年年就生了女儿，
今年怀孕的，
结婚了嘛，
我们结婚是没有任何的财产啊，
也没有任何的彩礼就结婚了。
我们是在广东的一个二线城市，
她是本地人，
我是外地过来的，
结婚就前几年，
然后还每天晚上会回来吃饭，
慢慢的他就整个晚上都不回来吃饭了，
最后的时候直接就经常不回来了。
我们现在的情况是分居了有三四年了，
他都没有回来，
他就在我们旁边租了一个房子，
他在这附近长大的，
所有的人都认识他，
有些人就跟我家婆说他在外面跟一个女人住在一起嘛，
我就一直是带着女儿自己在上班，
然后女儿上学，
就这几年他每天不回家，
以前的时候吵架，
他就经常冷战嘛，
动不动就把你微信拉黑，
手机拉黑也联系不到，
最近有时候就联系到他，
就是想说跟他离婚，
这个事情之前我跟他说要吃饭，
他拿不出来，
他说他没钱，
在这个过程当中太痛苦了，
我就觉得我很想离开这里，
不想待在这里，
我觉得这种事情对我来说，
对我是一个侮辱，
后面就。
跟他说到5万块，
他同意了，
但是他要我拿了证才肯，
就不肯了，
因为他这个人没有什么诚信的，
我就不肯，
我就找到这边的一个妇联去调解，
正好这几天以前的同事在一起聊天，
他就说了，
听到我老公跟别人说跟我合不来，
也想要分开，
他一直在外面连续的都有聊的，
15年的时候我发现过一次，
2022年的时候，
我也发现他同时跟很多个女的转账啊，
还有跟田那个也有一些转账，
就会问他嘛，
你问他东西，
他不理你往外面跑，
这十几年的婚姻，
孩子从来没有陪过，
孩子相当于是没有爸爸，
我也是没有老公的这种状态，
好在我家婆对我呢还很好，
还会帮助我们，
生活上面啊，
照顾我们的，
对我女儿也很好，
我们是没有房子的，
我们是跟他爸爸妈妈住在他们的房子里面，
他们是本地的那种宅基地嘛，
我们就一直住在这里，
她搬出去之后，
我们也还住在这里，
给我家婆还是一样的照顾我们，
她在外面跟一个女的住在一起，
还是我家婆告诉我的，
那个同事就建议我，
她说不要这么便宜，
他5万块钱不值什么钱，
她说我拿去租房子，
两三年就租完了，
她说叫我要么要多一点，
要么就30万，
要么就他们家的房子要转到我女儿的名下，
因为我离了他很快会带在个女人回来结婚，
再生一个儿子，
然走，
到时候他们会把我女儿赶出去，
说到时候我女儿没有保障，
要为我女儿将一个保障，
要把房子转到名下，
他们家如婆不同意，
我就不走，
就在这里，
如果我不离，
他永远都带不回那个女人。
继子，
他的外。
但是呢，
孩子他也带不回来，
他这样建议我，
但这几天我想了一下，
如果要争这个东西，
就会有很多麻烦的事情，
也很痛苦，
所以我想叫薇薇姐帮我出下主意，
我该怎么办？
孩子是想要像16岁，
16上高中了，
但是孩有一个情况，
因为小孩一直都是没到爸陪伴嘛，
他在上初中的时候就出现了一点问题，
他在学校有这种感觉，
他要用语光看别人一个很难受，
他好不容易考上了一个高中，
但是他很难去上学，
每天都感觉在学校里面很痛苦，
所以小孩这件事情上，
这两年也磨的我怕很痛苦啊，
真的是不知道怎么搞，
我们也看了医生，
也做了咨询，
也做了治疗，
还是没有改变。
小孩子这个问题上，
我从来没有跟他说，
他爸来在外面找人呢，
他爸在外面怎么怎么样，
我从来没跟他说，
我跟他爸爸的关系在小孩面前我从来没有提，
但是小孩这么大了，
他肯定会感觉到，
但我不知道怎么跟他开口，
以前同事还是这样，
我说跟小孩说开，
但是都没有说，
小孩到现在还没有去上个高中，
已经在家休了差不多两个星期了，
他上个学期也是一个学期，
基本上一大半都是在家里休学，
我带着去看一下医生，
有些医生说他是属于焦虑了，
有点社交恐惧啊，
干嘛的，
反正他就是上不了学，
小孩的问题他也不管，
我也一直带小孩看医生，
吃中药调身体，
那如果我是你的话，
现在对于我来说，
男人在外面有女人这个事情屁都不算，
现在对于我来说的话，
可能是想尽一切办法让我的孩子在一个宽松的。
环境，
比较喜欢的人际关系当中，
让他变得健康起来，
比起给他争一套房，
给他争什么保障，
真不如现在这个阶段能够让他成为一个健康的、
阳光的、
正常的孩子。
如果说你的情绪被你的老公在外面有女人同居被这些影响，
所有的时间精力都花到了这些事情上的话，
那可能就错过了孩子最佳的挽救期了。
我说挽救这个词一点都不夸张啊，
就是你的孩子现在是一个崩溃的边缘，
需要有人挽救他，
要有人把更多的时间精力爱花在他的身上。
房子这个事情，
因为孩子纠缠在这种关系上，
为他争一套房子，
如果他心理不健康，
有那套房子有什么意义？
我也只是同时这样建议，
我以前小孩从小到大都是我就带他，
这几年他长大了一点，
我上班也很忙，
就每天都加班，
我也是不想回到这个家里面嘛，
我每天也回的很晚，
可能这两年也是对孩子的陪伴少了一点，
很少跟小孩说什么话，
在一起的时候也是为他，
现在大了嘛，
给了他很多建议，
他听不进去，
有的时候孩子需要的可能不是建议哦，
孩子需要的可能就是深入下来，
去了解一下他有没有在学校被欺负，
有没有被排你自己之前了解过，
嗯，
他没有这方面的问题，
他上不了学，
这个问题都是源于他自己，
他有人多的地方，
他就感觉他的余光要看上别人，
他的注意力就在两边，
很难集中注意力，
就会感觉到很难受，
旁边的人嘛。
抖腿啊，
或者是做一些什么小动作，
他就很容易被注意到，
跟你说的那些，
我也问过他，
他就说没有。
他最开始的起因是上初三下学期的时候，
他就感觉就是他的前面有个男孩子很喜欢往后面看，
他就感觉那个人在看他，
他说他一回头那个人就是往后面看，
而且他很讨厌那个男孩子嘛，
他觉得男孩子很臭啊干嘛的，
后来就变成了他总是要去看两边，
总是要看旁边有没有人在看他，
那就直接变成了他只要在人多的地方，
注意力就会在一个方上面，
在两边。
就假设我的孩子，
哎，
十来岁的时候，
十几岁的时候，
十五六岁的时候出现了这样的症状，
他抑郁，
他焦虑或干嘛干嘛的话，
我在想我能做到什么，
我可以做到停下来不工作，
然后就是带着他到处吃吃喝喝，
带着他去他想去的地方，
他喜欢的人，
他喜欢追星，
我就陪他追星，
他喜欢看人家的谁唱歌啊跳舞啊什么的，
看相声啊，
看脱口秀啊什么的，
我就陪着他去看脱口秀，
因为人生可能关键处要紧处就这么几步，
就如果这个阶段我不陪着他的话，
可能未来的发展方向我不知道他会变成什么样子，
他的抑郁的情况会发展是什么样子，
我是说我自己的切身的感受啊，
所以说现在你的这个阶段的话，
这男人出不出男人跟谁说这个事情还有那么重要吗？
我的面子还有那么重要吗？
我的屈辱，
我的尊严还有那么重要吗？
还有什么比我的孩子健康更重要吗？
那为这个婚姻还要继续下去吗？
如果离开这段婚姻，
带着孩子能换一个环境，
换一个不认识的环境，
能重新开始，
让孩子有一个宽松的环境，
甚至包括学校都可以换，
就是学校里面的那些人他不喜欢，
咱就换一个学校，
换一个环境。
小孩儿这个问题他应该不是说换一个环境就能好了，
因为他初中是这样，
上了高中换了一个环境的，
也是这样，
他高一的时候没有分科，
在那个班是这样子，
到高二分了科，
又身边的同学又换了一批，
还是这样子。
那工作这个事情我也想过，
但是因为我已经是40岁了，
找工作的话，
可能后面没有那么好找，
我现在这份工作呢，
收入还是可以的，
只是说加班多一点，
我就怕失去了这份工作，
那以后再那去吧，
那就下了班多陪陪他，
小孩呢，
他也不是说他不想上学，
他就说他也不想休学，
但是他真他去了学校好难受，
又去不了，
所以他还自己也不知道怎么办。
我的话也是总是在陪孩子看医生干嘛的，
我之前也想过辞了工，
然后去小孩子学校附近找个房子陪他一起上学，
但是后来又想下去工作这个方面，
到后面可能很难再找到有这种收入的工作了，
因为年龄在那里，
我们也没有什么专业技术能力，
我现在如果不解束这段关系，
小孩高中毕业之后，
因为我们已经分居了有三四年了嘛，
我怕到时候男方去起诉我离婚，
我跟他的消费关系完全不一样了，
他是有一分钱就把这分钱花。
嗯，
他是每天都在外面吃喝，
从来都不回家吃的，
他在外面不止他一个人吃，
之所以他的钱都是花掉了，
我就是属于精打细算的那一种，
这几年我还存了一点钱，
有个几十万，
他没有钱，
他到时候去起诉我，
到时候还分我的钱走，
我有这种担忧的话，
我也理解你啊，
如果你有这种担忧的话，
我觉得当赚了断，
那他意思是说我只拿他同意的那个5万块，
拿了就走了嘛，
这样的话他也分不到你的钱，
然孩的问题，
他说小孩要跟他，
我同意说小孩跟他，
但是呢，
小孩是我来管他，
每个月给2000块钱，
小孩的生活费，
医药费的话是因外付，
我怕他到时候再取，
如果我走了之后，
后面肯定会带人进来，
我就怕到时候我的小孩就回不去这个家了，
那小孩什么保障都没有，
本来我是想说就让他们家把这个房子转到小孩名下，
让他们家他爷爷奶奶，
他姑姑他们都有居住钱，
也帮爷爷奶奶他们养老之类的，
但是说这个东西可能要经过很长时间一个拉扯，
也不知道能不能行，
多了钱，
你说十万二十万，
他可能也不同意，
他最多只拿5万块，
但是我就觉得很不甘心，
这点钱就在这里十几年，
我一个人带着孩子，
又上班又带孩子，
他就跟一单身一样，
在外面潇洒化过，
他做出这样的事情来，
所以觉得很不甘心，
有时候就觉得想要多一点，
要么让他付出更大的代价，
你有这些想法，
为孩子考虑，
就是当妈妈的你有爱在这里，
能不能实现这个事情啊？
你可以试一下，
能给孩子争取，
当然是好。
但是争取。
不到的话也要释然，
因为这个决策权不在你的手里嘛，
那没办法，
今天素颜那边打电话过来，
我说5万块钱，
我现在有点反悔了，
我觉得太少了，
他就说他见过了，
他说这个已经是很好了，
我已经拿到了很那个的，
他如果去法院判的话，
甚至可能会没有，
但是他要分你的钱，
那你的这个犯罪成本不太低了吗？
你一个男的，
他说他有犯罪，
你可以去起诉他，
但是他这种道德的问题，
他说他也管不了，
那我不认识你，
还有男的问题要卖我吗？
我不知道怎么办法，
对荐我真的是关于孩子，
他又关于这样婚姻，
你钱少了我不甘心，
钱多了他又不肯拿，
那我就想拖着，
因为我想姑娘，
我好怕姑娘。
我说这句话可能有点戳心窝子了，
但是真的是我的心里话，
我希望这句话能让你惊醒过来，
或许你的孩子的情绪是受你直接影响才变成今天这样的，
如果你不当机立断，
你还陷入这样的情绪反复当中的话，
你的孩子会越来越严重。
这是我的感受，
未必一定是精准的，
但我的感受就是这样，
你的孩子今天情绪之所以出问题，
可能很大一部分原因是基于你情绪反复在拉扯，
情绪反复在内耗，
情绪反复陷在负面的人际关系当中拔不出来，
所以孩子才会变成那样。
我也反思过，
有可能是因为如果你想救救你的孩子，
很多时候就是要把你从这些负面的人际关系当中抽离出来，
当断则断，
不要再。
似乎说今天在乎3万块钱、
5万块钱，
我的孩子的心理健康，
对于我来说的话，
可能不是今天这3万块钱、
5万块钱能够比拟得了的。
刚才我看到有评论区有姐妹说，
龙飞，
并不是所有人都像你这样啊，
经济上这么有能力，
敢于辞职，
敢于陪孩子去到处旅行啊什么的，
就是对于我来说的话，
哪怕我经济条件没有今天这么好，
我也敢这么干，
为什么？
因为在我的世界里面，
健康、
心理健康、
身体健康永远排在第一位，
挣钱多和少，
只是住房子大和小的区别，
只是在哪个城市生活的区别，
只是买菜贵和便宜的区别。
但是孩子的身体健康和心理健康，
我不知道该怎么形容啊，
就算我没有今天的这个条件，
就算我是一个普通人，
我也可以。
如果说人生紧要处就这么一两步，
陪伴他和不陪伴他，
他的那个心理健康状况的话，
差距就有那么大的话，
那我也可以做到，
那我应该要跟小孩儿说明白这个事情吗？
我该怎么开口说？
我承认小孩现在这样子，
跟我以前就知道他这些种种的时候，
情绪不稳定是有很大的关系，
我现在也成长了一些，
就是说没有那么生气了，
已经做到没有那么那个了，
但是小孩已经是有问题了，
少在孩子面前抱怨，
少在孩子没有娶你的事儿，
然后没有在他面前说过，
就是他爸爸，
我就很少说，
只是说有时候的话。
钱的时我就跟他说，
我说问你爸要去，
他又不肯，
他都不愿意跟他爸联系，
至于他在我面前还从来不去，
他看他跟他爸都没有什么感情，
你让他问他爸要钱，
你咋想的呢？
我说你不要我他也给人家花了，
那你不觉得这是变相的把压力给到了你的女儿吗？
可能是有，
但是他不要的话，
我们都要不了一分钱，
包括小孩子看病啊什么的，
都是我在负担，
小孩子的所有的东西都是我在负担，
他甚至都不知道小孩现在上几年级，
在哪个班，
老师是谁，
她都不知道，
我话就讲到这里了啊，
供你参考好不好？
嗯，
最后就是说我们的话，
小孩子的那个跟着他，
因为他大了嘛，
他可以走过来跟我生活吗？
小孩子后喊在他爸这边可以这样子吗？
可以啊，
只是有一点不甘心，
如果我从这里走了的话，
他们就说就会立马有人来生孩子，
到时候孩子他们那些人就会对你的孩子不好，
把你孩子赶出去干嘛呢？
我也不想便宜了他，
哪怕我在这里拖着，
因为我已经40岁了，
我没有打算再拖着，
没有打算再生小孩儿，
我就在这里拖着他，
她永远都名正言顺不了，
她永远都进不了这个来，
我也这样想，
就这样子下去，
姐妹啊，
如果你跟我说你老公是千万身家亿身家，
这样拖着或许有意义，
你老公就是这么普通的一个男的，
这么普通的一个家庭，
你拖着有什么意义？
没错吧，
你今天要是告诉我说你老公是亿万身家，
好，
那我就拖着，
我给我孩子挣一个亿万的遗产，
你老公这么普通，
这么普通的家庭，
这么不上道的家。
你蒸什么破锅碗破瓢盆有什么用，
因为我也没有房子住完，
到时候还要自己去租房子，
最起码在这里有个地方住的，
我家伙也会照顾我们的生活起居，
是个用的到那些生活，
我家伙也从来不问我们要好。
在这样的环境下，
假设如果继续过这样的生活，
你的孩子抑郁了，
不学习了，
不出门了，
不与人社交了，
那又有什么意义呢？
住在这里有什么意义呢？
小孩儿不是说抑郁，
我们看到很多医生，
医生都没有说是抑郁，
可能有一些余光恐惧或者是社交恐惧之类的，
他现在不是已经高中了嘛，
如果他好好的能去上学，
倒是没有什么那个，
但是他现在不想去上学，
如果要不你再问问那种就是教育专家，
或者孩子的心理学这方面的专家，
再问一问，
看怎么能帮到孩子，
好吧，
那卢菲姐给我的建议就是拿了钱还是离开这里，
是不换个环境，
包括孩子换个环境，
多陪陪孩子，
或许还有的缓。
我的性格也是比较内向的那种，
我跟孩子在一起，
现在也不知道跟他说什么，
就是你自己要学会快乐起来，
要有自己的朋友，
要有自己的社交圈子，
要有自都有爱好，
你要我有福，
也要我有自己的朋友，
休息的时候也会跟朋友去逛街啊，
跟朋友一起玩啊，
也会带小孩一起去，
好，
那我们就聊到这里了啊，
嗯，
好，
谢谢，
嗯，
拜拜，
临了临了的话我再多说几句吧，
本着我的良心，
本着我做事情的这个认真负责的这个态度，
我觉得你。
也需要去看心理医生，
我知道这句话说出来你肯定心里会排斥的，
举个不是很恰当的例子啊，
就像张雪峰老师，
有一次直播的时候，
有人指出来说他的嘴唇颜色不太好，
让他去查一下心脏，
他的第一反应就是反驳吗？
这是符合人性的，
同样的道理，
我今天说出来这句话，
我觉得你需要去看心理医生，
你心里也会排斥我，
也会想反驳我，
但是你要知道啊，
我们两个人是萍水相逢，
我对你是没有恶意的，
我收了你300块钱，
我要基于我的良心和专业，
和我对你认真负责的态度，
以我的判断，
我认为你需要去进行长期的心理咨询和治疗，
他也是你的一个情绪的出口，
只有当你自己把你自己的内心理顺了之后，
你才有可能跟你的女儿好好的相处，
在评论区的姐妹们，
请你们也不要用恶意的或者说戏谑的这种态度来看待这件事情，
我们就作为一个善良的人，
就作为一个普通人，
以我们自己的判断啊，
我们觉得刚才连麦的这个姐妹，
她是不是需要一些心理辅导，
是不是需要有人能够帮她从这样一个执念当中说我亏了，
我不甘心，
从这样一个念当中把他拉出来，
他才有好日子过，
尽管他说他有朋友，
尽管他说他有兴趣爱好，
但很多东西是不是交心了，
是不是成为你生命中很重要的一部分吗？
还是说你生命当中现在更重要的精力是放在我？
跟这个男人怎么极限拉扯，
我怎么让这个男人痛苦，
放在这件事情上的话，
你就不可能真正的幸福。
只有当有一天，
你真正的摒弃了，
舍弃了这段关系，
不再纠缠这个男的，
再管我跟他在一起，
是谁亏了，
谁赚了，
是谁付出多了，
谁付出少了，
只是认栽，
承认我自己瞎，
承认我自己没有眼光，
承认我选错了人好到那一刻，
你才有可能真正的幸福。
你好起来，
你幸福起来，
你快乐起来，
你一念放下，
你万般自在，
你看什么都是美景，
你看什么都顺眼的时候，
孩子，
跟你生活在一起，
才有可能变好。
记得点赞关注哦。